لن تكتفي الصين باغراق اسواق وبيوت
العراقيين ببضائعها ايضا الى نشر ثقافتها
ولغتها عبره معاهده وشركات ثقافيه تجعلها
اكثر قربا الى بلاد الرافدين اقتصاديا
ربما عسكريا في المستقبل
ميزان التبادل التجاري فاقه 40 مليار
دولار سنويا بين العراق والصين بدا بالنمو
في عهد رئيس الوزراء الاسبق العبادي تلاه
توقيع اتفاقيات في عهد عبد المهدي ثم نفذ
جزء مما اتفق عليه في حقبه الكاظمي كل هذا
دفع جامعه بغداد الافتتاح معهد ومكتبه
للغه الصينيه يتم فيها تعليم الراغبين
للغه وترجمه العقود التي بات عددها
بالالاف بين الشركات العراقيه الصينيه
لدينا تعاون من خلال المكتب الاستشاري
لكليه اللغات في الترجمه
الخدمات لتجربه الوثائق والكتب الصينيه
وللغتين بالعكس يعني من العربي الى الصيني
الى العربي
من خلال السوق همم ما بين المنتج الصيني
والمستهلك في
يتركز عمل الشركات الصينيه بشكل اساسي في
جنوبي البلاد حيث مصادر النفط والغاز
تحديدا في مدينه البصره والتي تشغل
الشركات الصينيه نحو خمسه من اكبر حقول
النفط هناك لكن بكين تنتظر المزيد من
الفرص الاستثماريه النفطيه والغازيه حيث
يعد العراق ثالثه مصدر النفط الى الصين
بعد روسيا والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
لا تتطلب شروط تعجيزيه للعمل ليست لديها
لدي نظر سياسيه بعيده المدى
الضغط على العراق هذه جعل الاسواق
العراقيه همم تاجر عراقي حكومه عراقيه همم
همم تعمل على استحقاب رؤوس الاقمار
الصينيه للعمل بالعراق لانه شروطهم سهله
وبسيطه وسبل عيش بسيطه
علاقه اقتصاديه لطالم ارتبطت قوتها
بالسياسه وميزان القوى الاقليميه والدوليه
في العراق
الاستقرار النسبي ومغادره الشركات الغربيه
في البلاد دفع الصيني لاستثمار اكثر من 10
مليارات دولار قابله لزياده في مجال
الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه بحسب تقارير
اقتصاديا
سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد